la mayoría de los ataques ocurren al
anochecer Entonces como todas las noches
estos hombres salen a patrullar
el peligro acecha justo detrás de los
árboles
trata de pasar desapercibido se quita la
camiseta de color vivo
esta manada de elefantes salvajes podría
atacar en cualquier momento Y si están
acercando a la aldea
tienda por la noche los elefantes vienen
a buscar comida en nuestros Campos lo
destruyen todo
es terrible en cuanto están en los
campos lo arrasan todo no podemos hacer
mucho intentamos ahuyentarlos prenden
fuego pero no siempre sirve según las
estadísticas del gobierno los elefantes
matan a unas 10 personas al mes
tinache faraujo director del Parque
Nacional tiene la terrible
responsabilidad de recoger los cadáveres
hoy transporta el ataúd de una
desafortunada víctima
recibimos una noticia Trágica un hombre
de unos 30 años murió pisoteado por un
elefante
es devastador
otra persona muerta y otra familia de
luto
[Música]
en la aldea comienza el funeral
los cantos y bailes se mezclan con un
profundo sentimiento de rabia
los animales no deben dominar al hombre
todos los años muere gente
era mi hermano estoy muy triste por eso
pero siguen protegiendo a los elefantes
Esta última víctima murió mientras
Trabajaba en un campo cercano la policía
llega al lugar para investigar las
circunstancias
los elefantes lo persiguieron por todo
el campo le habían desgarrado la ropa y
cuando llegamos lo vimos tirado en el
suelo con los ojos vidriosos
hace 20 años no teníamos estos casos la
población humana está creciendo la
población animal También tienen que
compartir los mismos recursos estamos
hablando de competir por el agua con los
animales
hay demasiados elefantes la preservación
de las especies en peligro de extinción
ha sido una prioridad del gobierno
zimbabwe ha visto aumentar la población
de elefantes hay 100.000 paquidermos en
el país
convirtiéndolo en el hogar de casi una
cuarta parte de todos los elefantes de
África pero algunos especialistas dicen
que hay el doble de elefantes para los
recursos disponibles este guardabosques
fue contratado para proteger a los
gigantescos mamíferos pero dice que la
situación insostenible
tenemos que hacer algún tipo de
regulación de la población tal vez
venderlos o dar licencias de casa O tal
vez trasladarlos a otros lugares
los guardabosques acaban de matar al
elefante sospechoso de estar detrás de
la muerte del aldeano
el elefante tenía una pata hinchada
seguramente por eso estaba agresivo y
quería matar o atacar
que usamos
tras el sacrificio la carne del elefante
es repartida entre los aldeanos
whenlife is Under 3 cuando una vida está
en peligro no nos arrepentimos matamos
al animal
a los que dicen que no debemos matar al
elefante que se los lleven para que
puedan vagar libremente por sus ciudades
los estudios demuestran que la mayoría
de los zimbabuenses que viven cerca de
la vida Silvestre guardan rencor hacia
los elefantes no solo por los ataques
sino también por la destrucción de
cultivos y propiedades por este motivo
las ong de conservación de la fauna
silvestres luchan por hacerse oír
necesitamos una manera adecuada de
administrar nuestra tierra nuestra fauna
y nuestro medio ambiente porque ahora se
dice que hay demasiados elefantes
Eso debería ser una ventaja para
nosotros no un problema eso significa
que somos un país que protege a los
elefantes
mientras que la superpoblación de
elefantes se ha convertido en un
problema en zimbabwe en otros países
africanos siguen siendo una especie en
peligro de extinción
[Música]